okay I grew up on two sides of the
George Washington Bridge half my life
that I lived in New Jersey the other
half I lived in New York
on Sullivan Street in Greenwich Village
with my dad Vincent giganti the boss of
the Genovese crime family and I was born
in Manhattan
and my family lived in a four-room
apartment with two German Shepherds
by the time I was six months old my dad
decided to move us out to New Jersey
and my mom was able to choose from
whatever houses she wanted we ended up
moving to Old Japan New Jersey
which is probably the best thing that
ever happened because my dad being who
he was he was the head of the Genovese
crime family in Manhattan but he was
also the head of the of the commission
and
that being said
um there was a lot of
insurmountable things that
the family had to go through
to get him
to where he was in the end so we were
five children I me being the youngest I
was I came
10 years after the
um the youngest child which was my
brother and for me it was I was a change
of life baby nobody expected me
um my dad
you know he he didn't want any more
children and when my mom got pregnant he
was like oh my God
um but
you know here I am and I I am the change
of life baby in the sense that I was
able to see things from a different
perspective than the rest of the family
they were so much older and they were
already born into my dad's world in the
sense that if my dad asked them to do
something they would do it for him so
um my sisters and I were to take care of
my mom mostly me at the end because
um again being the youngest as an
Italian Catholic
child when I grew up this is what you
did you took care of your own soul I
think I heard
you know my dad's last words to me and
his first words to me were take care of
your mother so that was my job here
right
but I had ideas of my own
and uh I was the Renegade you know I
didn't want to be a part of that world
um I loved my dad
but um I know what a very very young age
something was not right I didn't know
what he did until I was about 16 years
old
but at a very young age
children know things they don't
necessarily know how they know but they
absolutely know that there's something
not right and I knew it I am grew up
knowing never to speak or ask questions
um you know or I would ask my sister but
never my dad
but my first experience with my dad at a
very young age I was five years old
I was underneath my grandmother's
um
she she had she had a
we have four room apartment but but the
dining room table was huge and
um I was under there playing and nobody
knew where I was at the time because you
know it was the Forum apartment my my
grandmother my mother were outside
um and they were either shopping or
whatever and
I was under the table and there was
Italian music playing in the background
and
all of a sudden I hear this Ruckus right
and and I hear men and I hear now my
father when I tell you my father spoke
you know below a whisper that's how it
was for him but not at that time because
he was very young
but he really didn't say much
and I hear the Ruckus and I hear them
bringing in
a man who they were about to beat him
and so I'm I crawled up to the farthest
part of the
dining room table and I just sat there
waiting and I can hear the Italian music
in the background
and all of a sudden I hear the punches
boom boom boom like one right after the
other and the guy hit the ground
and then I see my father's hands and the
only reason why I know is because he
would wear this pinky ring I knew it was
his
so I just watched him beat him
and at some point the man's head turned
my way and I see his eyes were like
almost like half Mass like he was going
out right and then all of a sudden the
blood and the blood started to trickle
to me like to my feet
and I started to shake uncontrollably
but I didn't say a word I didn't want
anybody to know I was there
and
um
I
just stood there until it was over and
the last thing I remember is my dad
stepping on this man's face
and saying in a very low tone I'm done
with him get him the [__] out of here
and then they bodily picked him up and
took him out
and then my mother and my grandmother
came back
and they were like where is she where's
Rita and they found me underneath the
table and my mother dragged me out I'm
crying and shaking uncontrollably
and she's trying to tell me that
everything is okay Daddy just got mad
you know they're telling me all the
things you would try and tell a kid
and in that moment I um shut down my
whole body shut down
and I was petrified of my father after
that
I had this feeling that if I did
anything wrong somehow I was going to be
hurt that way or killed even that was in
the back of a five-year-old mind
not too long after that my anxiety
attacks began
and I would be afraid to go to school I
didn't want to leave home I didn't want
to leave my mother
so I
you know I would stay home constantly I
was falling behind in school I realized
today like after everything I'm like how
did they even like get me to the next
grade they got me to the next grade
because of who my father was wasn't like
they were going to hold me back
so but
what that did to me was you know I'm I'm
in high school when I hit high school I
have a sixth grade reading level you
know and I can't I can't get my grades
to where they need to be
so that being said by the age of seven
I've con you know I've I've I went
through another traumatic experience
with a crossing guard who was an old man
you know if he was in his 80s you know
I mean that's just he just seemed very
old and he was Italian and he would
speak Italian because I would walk back
and forth to school
and I understood some of it but I didn't
speak it so but one day he groped me you
know from behind and
um you know he he did it in a very
disgusting way and he was speaking in
Italian and I ran home and I told my mom
and you know I'm seven years old like
and I told my mom I said you know this
you know he touched me I said and I I
don't feel I don't feel right about it
and I'm hysterical crying and I I said
you know what are you gonna do like I
wanted to know what she was going to do
and she basically just took me by the
shoulders and she said okay you're not
going to walk to school anymore she said
but I can't tell Daddy about the man
and I said why I said he hurt me you
know he
and she said to me because I don't know
what he would do to him
and he said what do you mean I said he
needs to do something to him like
somebody stick up for me like I had no
voice at that moment you know and she
said no
we can't she says I don't want the man
to get hurt
and I was so angry at that point I was
like [__] this and I was like this is
just not right nobody's hearing me my
voice isn't hurt
after that I started to get panic
attacks
now I am a psychic medium and healer
what nobody understood back then was
that I was an empath and an empath is
somebody that can feel everything and
everyone around them
so I was carrying my mother's anxiety
and depression I was carrying my
father's fears and whenever anxieties he
was having my sisters and brothers I
couldn't tell the difference between my
own and theirs
so I would consistently try and help my
mother because I could see that she was
struggling with the fact that my father
was who he was
there was nothing
she really could do about it
and she would go into these deep
depressions
and so I would take her energy and try
and help her and then I would go into
deep depressions myself
and throughout the course of my life
it became
anxiety
panic attacks by the time I was 10 OCD
entered
obsessive-compulsive disorder
I imagine now I realize I created that
because I needed a way to feel like I
was in control of something
so it would be
struggling every day to pick out a shirt
because one didn't feel right because
somebody was going to die if I picked
out you know the wrong color or the
wrong pair of pants or whatever
I deprived myself of things that I loved
peanut butter you know I couldn't eat
peanut butter for the longest time
because if I did somebody in my family
would die you know
so but I realized as I got older and
looking back it was just a way for me to
cope and it was fabulous because it in
my opinion it kept me from going quote
unquote crazy right
so as I got older
I would see what was going on in my
grandmother's apartment I was 10 years
old watching a group of men sit around
that table you know everything was on
cartoons were on always cartoons he had
to have the cartoons on
the radio was playing and there would be
you know they were writing either notes
back and forth to each other somebody
would get up and whisper in his ear
I'm watching this whole thing and I'm
going who is he like I don't understand
and I'm never allowed to ask questions
so I'm trying to figure out who he is
I'm listening one ear to him I'm
listening there the ear to the you know
to the
to the cartoons
and then you know in the end of
everything he would give the orders
Whispering the phone was always off the
hook
phone was never on the hook and you know
we had those old rotary phones back then
he never spoke on the phone so in 40
years until he went to jail for the last
time his voice was never on a phone
um so he would whisper to them
all the papers got
torn up they either got burnt or they
got flushed down the toilet everybody
would get up everybody went and did what
they had to do whatever he told them to
do
end of story
as I got older
again in my head I'm questioning he's
important
he does these things that I don't
understand
but now we're at a point where he's
gone up in the organization so he veto
Genovese was somebody that absolutely
adored my father and he was the head of
the Genovese crime family at that time
my father was 16. at that time you
weren't allowed to box but this man took
my father under his wing
and of course you put them in the boxing
ring and he made money and he saw how my
father could you know take care of
himself and be an enforcer if he needed
so that didn't last very long because
um yeah he had several fights my dad
yeah maybe he had 25 fights and he won
almost all of them but
the idea was Vito had him at that point
and my dad came
listen my my grandma my and my
grandfather were immigrants okay they
came off the boat from Italy my
grandmother in Italy
had money they had status her father was
a doctor and a pharmacist my grandmother
was following in his footsteps okay they
had servants they were very well to do
she left all of that to come here with
my grandfather who was an ill man at the
time okay
um
she got here
they had nothing she became a seamstress
he was a jeweler okay so my father grew
up with not a lot of money and my mother
too no money holes in their shoes
everything
so
growing up like that my father was
looking for a way to make money boxing
was one of them he did work a couple of
jobs but when Vito got a hold of him
that was it it was like you're coming
with me
so he became his driver
and then at one point
um Vito took him in and said okay you
know this is going to be a way that you
get ahead and this was the Costello
shooting okay my father had to go and
prove himself
so he was supposed to kill Costello and
in the process he misses okay
and so anybody who misses normally
they're dead the next day okay
Avita loved him and so
my father stayed alive
they went to court of course Costello
said I don't know who it was
Costello retires
and my father gets brought up in the
ranks once again
and so he goes then he goes to jail with
veto Vito dies in jail my father comes
out and slowly
he becomes who he is the head of the
crime family
but he always has somebody in front of
him saying that they're him
you know meaning
that they're really the head but my
father's in the background being
protected
at a certain point in time my father
you know as being
I want to say the FBI is all of him
right so at some point he decides
because he never wanted to go back to
jail again after the first time he
decides he's going to create a Persona
of himself that he's crazy you know
paranoid schizophrenia
quite honestly he could have won an
Academy Award he did it so well
people believed him his own doctors
believed him
but I'm sure some of them were
paid to believe so to speak
and uh
he would check himself in and out of
Mental Hospitals
when he thought that the FBI was really
close to him
and so
backtracking a little bit
now I'm let's say 16 right and I'm I'm
hearing all these stories about him
people in school because we live in this
New Jersey you know suburbian area and
so there were people that weren't
allowed to hang out with me kids that
weren't allowed to hang out with me
but there was also
um families that were gracious
and that we've we connected to
my father lived with us for a year
because I was six months when we moved
out he lived with us for a year
we gave the police department a donation
for fifty dollars
my sister actually went and gave them
the check
and said this is a donation from our
family
they took it as a bribe arrested him and
my mother
and that moment my father said
I'm going back to the city I'm going to
go live with my mother
so
in that moment he knew things had to
change
and so now he's starting to wear a
bathrobe slippers pee cap walking the
streets talking to parking meters you
know talking to himself
and I'll never forget him saying to me
he'd come in when we'd come to visit
he'd come in and say come on we're going
to walk now he was very afraid to
I never got hit by my father never
really even got yelled at by my father
because of my anxiety and my panic
attacks
he was very very leery of
um reprimanding me in any way so
he would take me to what they called The
Cafe which is where he played cards and
he had his business and all that
so he'd say come walk with me now the
man was
almost six feet tall
I'm 5'1
pieces so he would you know he'd go
through the whole thing of his hair it
was messed up put his pee cap on the
whole robe slippers everything he's all
an act all next
and
part of me giggled you know when he did
this because I watched him get into that
you know that um character I'll say
right
so he'd say come on we're gonna walk
and then as we got outside they say come
on hold me up he said you know make like
you're holding me up and I'm thinking if
anybody's taping us if anybody's looking
at us he's six feet I'm five one like
how am I holding him up anywhere right
so there would be people that would be
passing us and tipping their hat because
they know him so out of respect they
would tip their hat there were others
that would walk by and give us the look
like
what is this you know and I'd be like
mind you in my head I'd be like mind
your business that's my father so there
was that piece of me that that was my
father you know and I loved him and
there was the other piece like
[__] why do I have to do this like I I'm
not comfortable doing this you know and
we get to the cafe and we'd sit down and
I'd watch him play cards
and there were I want people to
understand that there were sides to my
father that nobody really knew okay
everybody thought this was a glamorous
lifestyle and that we all lived high on
the hog
and it's just not true we suffered
dearly for what he was involved in so
um before I actually found out who he
was and and all of that
you know I would be hearing these these
things in school people would say oh
there's the mafia princess I'll follow
this I'll follow that you know to the
point where one day
um there was this one particular girl
who was spreading Big Time rumors and
you know I just had had enough
even though I didn't know the truth I
really had had enough of everybody
talking about me
and so I grabbed her one day in the in
the
stall of the the bathroom in in my uh
High School
and I just beat the [__] out of her
you know she came out at the stall both
her friends went in with her I had a
friend that was watching and she came to
me and she said she's in the bathroom
I come into the bathroom both those
girls were in the bathroom I said get
out like that now she heard my voice I'm
waiting for her to come out of the stall
and she came out of the stall and she
said like she was acting acting very
cocky and I says you know I've had
enough of you making fun of my family or
saying things that and she kind of went
to
come at me a bit and I just took her
down I wrapped my hands around her
hair
pulled her down and I hit her her here
on the sink of the bathroom
and interestingly enough
in that moment I went to go hit her
again and I stopped myself
and my friend Michelle came in and she
said to me
somebody's coming and I said all right
I'm done with her and those are the
words my father said right is I didn't
even realize this till after the fact
so
I didn't like myself after that I didn't
want to be
the person that that person that was
you know um
yes I was sticking up for my family yes
she probably to served the beaten but I
didn't want to conduct myself that way
I'm not that person
so
at 16 at that point I was 16 at that
point I said I got to find out what's
going on because now I'm starting to
believe things that I don't know if
they're true or not
so I go to a family friend
and I sitting down with her and I said
please tell me what's happening I said I
need to know this is what just happened
to me I have blood all over me
so
she said to me you don't know
I said no
and she said sit down and she explained
everything to me who my father was what
he did all of all of it including that
he was the head of the commission
and I if you would if you could have saw
my face everything drained right out of
me but in that moment it was like all
the pieces of the puzzle snapped into
place
and I said son of a [__] in my head I'm
going this is why I have such anxiety
and panic and I'm out of my body half
the time I can't you know I'm I'm trying
to stay grounded and I can't little did
I know I had these gifts that were
coming right and nobody in my family
understood that nobody but my
grandmother she did have visions okay
which I found out afterwards
so they don't know what to do with me I
go in and out of these depressions
um can't eat for weeks on end losing
weight the whole thing
but every single time it happened
three weeks later somehow by the grace
of God
I get an urge to have McDonald's I don't
know why it was McDonald's and I don't
know why it was Chinese food right we go
to McDonald's I get two big you know
French fries
and a shake and I'd be dipping the fries
in the shake because I happen to love
sweet and salty
my appetite would open and then I would
come back to normal again
but there's another several pieces of
the story so
at age 11 I knew I was gay right I felt
that in my bones I knew it I was never
going to be with a man I was never going
to get married like I was expected to do
and have children
I would certainly take care of my mother
because I was groomed for it from the
day I was born
so
at 11 years old I'm holding the secret
now now my father's got a million
Secrets right
he is who he is he's lying to
everybody's lying even to us for certain
things right
he goes and he has another family on top
of all of this
so
this is what happens in that lifestyle
though I want everybody to understand
so he has we'll call her a Paramore
he ends up having three children with
her
all very close to my age one two years
old or one only six months apart so
she and my mother was pregnant at the
same time one two years after me
gets better
both those women's names with the same
name Olympia
how that happens in this lifetime I
don't know how many olympias do we know
I won I I know one my mother and Olympia
dukak is is the only other one I know
but both names are Olympia
so obviously he can't make a mistake
whoever he's talking to or with
um
so he has this other family now my
mother
my mother knows
my mother
only confides in my sister who's 15
years old
my sister had a bear a lot because she
was the oldest
and so my father confided in her and my
mother confided in her none of us knew
until later on in life
he kept it under wraps and absolutely
nobody know
so this is why my mother was so
depressed and angry and upset
so moving through that piece
at 19
I decide I'm going to try and come out
to my mother and my father
I got myself together and at my mother's
house he comes to visit he came to visit
every so often in New Jersey
I got the
balls
to go into the room into the bedroom Sit
Them Down
sweating like an animal my Palms
everything
shaking like a leaf and I and they they
looked at me like what's wrong
and he said you know I have to tell you
something
and I said I'm gay I said I like women
and I thought I was going immediately I
thought my father was going to get up
and crack me right I just thought that
that was it
I got the complete opposite which scared
me more
he got because my mother looked at him
because she was like I don't know what
to do with this
so he just looked at me and he said a
lot of a lot of kids your age kids 19. a
lot of kids your age go through this
this is just you know this is just a
something you go through he said you're
experimenting it's okay he says you're
going to get married you're going to
have kids he says but I'm going to tell
you he says I don't want you to hang out
with these girls anymore that you hang
out with
now in an Italian Catholic Family you
couldn't hang out with boys or girls in
in mine anyway because now I'm gay right
so I was never allowed to really date
men
but I wasn't allowed to hang out with my
girlfriends either
get up
back in my room
hysterical crying
two days later I'm sick as a dog now I'm
sick often with upper respiratory okay
whether it's pneumonia whether it's you
know the whole thing with my throat my
ears everything now for some of you who
don't know what I do for a living being
a psychic medium healer
this area which we call the throat
chakra okay which is energy but it's a
it's called the throat chakra this is
the area where you speak your truth
I tried
and I had to jump right back in the
closet
so because I had to still lie about
everything I was getting ill from it
at the age of 24 I said I'm done
I told my mother this is who I am this
is who I'm always going to be this is
how I was born
and graciously my mother said to me
we're not going to tell your father I
said I don't care this is what I'm
telling you and she said listen to me
she goes I love you
I'm afraid for you because of the way
the world is and I'm afraid for your
soul because she was Catholic right and
I said listen to me
this is how I was made
so there's no God that made me this way
I'm explaining to her that doesn't love
me and doesn't want me to be who I need
to be I said I made peace with it I need
you to make peace with it and she did
she made peace with it
so I started to live my my life at 19 I
put myself in therapy
they didn't put me they didn't say go to
therapy I put myself in therapy okay
and
the first time in 19 years
well first I was told make sure you
don't talk about the family just talk
about your anxiety not the fact that my
anxiety was for my family but you know
they thought that that's just talk about
the anxiety okay and go to therapy
and I'm drilling the therapist on
you know if I tell you certain things
does that mean you're going to tell
other can you tell other people can you
go to you know uh the police can you go
to the FBI she doesn't even know what
I'm going to say yet and she's
reassuring me that she's it's private
confidentiality right
after three visits of grueling drilling
her I finally say okay this is what it
is
and I told her who my father was and
what the situation was
and she just looked at me with like deer
like headlights you know deer in the
headlight
and I just said is this something you
can handle and she said absolutely
and all of a sudden it was like a
thousand pounds came off of me
to be able to just speak it to someone
who didn't say to me
no you can't talk about this no this is
wrong no this is going against the
family no no no no no no
it was yes now
and that began the healing process for
me
and so
I do want to tell people
and I and I've always I always do this
in any interview I have
my father wasn't all bad
I'm going to tell you that there were
times where he was actually a human
being in the sense that he was a dad
okay he would when I was sick he I would
lay on his lap and he would rub my back
in my head until
I fell asleep
he would take care of that whole
you know part of New York that he ran
the whole village the West Village if
the elderly couldn't pay for their rent
or food my Dad paid for it he was very
generous in that way he was extremely
charismatic he probably could have been
the CEO of any company you know that he
could have created but he got caught up
and when he understood the power behind
what he was doing he couldn't give up
the power
it was never ever about the money for
him it was always about the power now I
really am the only one in this out of us
children who could get him up and dance
to Elvis because he loved Elvis
so there were times where I'd be in my
grandmother's we switched Apartments now
we were on LaGuardia and I'd say to him
come on I said I'm going to put Elvis on
let's dance and he what two left feet
couldn't dance for [__] but he would get
up and he would shimmy and do all of
that my mother would get up and shimmy
he'd come out of character for like
10-15 minutes
and then after that he go right back
into it now I witnessed him in character
I've witnessed doctors coming to check
him out and you know him you know
speaking in a way mimicking the cartoons
and saying God told me to do this and
God told me to do that and um
you know and he was my God you know I'm
I would have to turn and laugh because
it was funny in some sense and in the
other sense I'm like
this is just insanity and then when he
checked himself in to the mental
hospital he was on the third floor with
the people that were very ill they had
bipolar they had schizophrenia all of
that
and we would go and my energy because
I'm an empath would pick up everybody's
energy within 10 minutes of being in the
room with him I'd fall asleep because I
couldn't handle it okay
but I think that hurt me the most
because
and it's not that the murders weren't
yes that that was definitely
um it hurt me as well but I'm watching
him make a mockery
of the actual people that were really
ill you know and they would come in and
give him his pills and he would you know
I don't know how he did it but he was
able to hide the pills that they were
giving him for apparently the mental
stuff
they would leave the room he would open
his mouth show them that he swallowed it
they would leave he'd spit it out
in a you know tissue give it to my
mother and say take it home and flush it
so these and these with three week
stents that he would go in for
eign so as time went on
I wanted I didn't know what I wanted to
do in my life I did a lot of part-time
jobs I did a lot of things but I knew I
wanted to help people I didn't know how
I just knew I had to help people
and so I decided after doing a million
things I'm going to go to massage school
I was working for a chiropractor at a
time at that time and I was just working
the office like doing whatever he told
me to do even massage people and I
didn't even know that I that I could do
that and I was also a personal trainer
at the time
it was the first time in my life I made
my own money and I felt good about
myself
so from there I went to massage school
now when I when I got to massage schools
where I really realized I had gifts
because I was able to put my hands on
someone
and feel what was going on inside their
body I could see the liver I could see
the kidneys I could see the stomach
everything and I would hear these things
in my head saying okay they have an
issue with their kidneys they're going
to need to do this this and that blah
blah blah I didn't know who was speaking
it wasn't me but it was my voice but I
just knew it wasn't coming for me
so I would tell the person listen I
don't know if this is true but this is
what I'm hearing and they would look at
me like oh my God how did you know that
and I'm like oh God what did I do here
like I started I don't even know how I'm
doing this I said I don't know I just
have a knowing now a knowing in my work
is called clear cognizant clairsentient
is where I can feel stuff okay
so I'm
get through massage school I begin to
work on people immediately I'm helping
people heal themselves in multiple ways
not knowing how
until I reached the point where I have
my own Visions now I was raised Catholic
but I no longer practice
Catholicism and I haven't for a very
long time someone asked me I tell them
I'm spiritual but I did have visions
I've had visions of Christ I had visions
of mother Mary and these all were able
to get me to the place that I needed to
go with my work the more I cleared out
my own energy
the more I was able to do this other
work that I was doing so in other words
the more I cleared out my old family
stuff
and all the drama and all the craziness
that went on there the more energy I had
to do my work
so as time went on I was able to then
focus on that piece and also I was
trained by several people to
I want to say
cultivate my psychic senses so then I
was able to see and hear things
sometimes I could taste and even smell
depending on who I was working with
so that that was a real
blessing for me it got me to the point
where now I was helping people yes this
was here on the side but I was no longer
now
as connected as I was before okay and
no one can understand it they just
didn't understand what I was doing how I
could do it they didn't believe it
really you know
so
um one day I worked on my mom she was
not feeling great and I was practicing
one of the skills that I had and it was
called the laying on of the hands and I
sat there I said stand here I said let
me let me try something I said it was
something emotional that was going on
with her and I said to my niece stand
behind her
and I put my hands on my mother my
mother went down immediately like a
feather she just got limp and she felt
an incredible peace come over her
and she said to me what was that and I
said that was you releasing and spirit
coming through you they took it and now
you have your own energy back
she was blown away
she said to me this is what you do for
people I said yes I said but I don't do
it I said everybody does it themselves I
said you trusted me
so it happened I said when I'm working
with somebody I tell them this is
between you and spirit
I'm just a conduit I said and then if
they want to heal they heal you know
it's like leading the horse to the water
but you can't make them drink right
at that point felt like my mother was
like believed everything I did said
didn't matter and then slowly my family
started to understand it I should say my
sisters
um I don't really speak to my brothers
at this point well one of them I'm
starting to but after I wrote my book
they were not happy about it
so five years I'm sorry
15 years before I wrote the book Spirit
came to me and said you're going to
write a story you're going to write your
story start to write things down now it
will not come out for a while but it's
going to come out and you're going to
help the masses so I always ask that how
can I help the masses
I said okay so I started writing my
story
I just took I just took eight you know
like I went from just one experience
took that road about it and just kept
going
15 years later I'm introduced to a woman
who is going to help me now put it all
together
and it took about two years to actually
write
and it was extremely cathartic
but it was extremely exhilarating
because I knew that if when people read
it
that it was going to help them somehow
so many aspects to it the fact that I
was people could relate anybody could
relate to I don't care what you are
Jewish Italian you know whatever it is
you can relate to the family Dynamics
right
um
you can relate to the fact that I was
gay and I couldn't come out you could
relate to the fact that the women in my
home were suppressed
let not the men okay
and they they benefited the men
benefited although my brothers were
never made ever my father would never
allow that
so
um it comes time where I'm on my own and
my father's get you know he he gets
arrested he's in jail he's going in for
12 years okay
so my life is I'm living with a woman
I'm
you know I have my own life I have my
own business I'm thriving at this point
but the one piece that that's missing
is me making amends with my father
because I didn't know if he was going to
die in jail or not I didn't know if he
was going to make it out
and I kept asking Spirit show me how to
forgive
show me how to
forgive all of them not just him my
mother you know the whole family the
whole dynamic I said I want to be rid of
this because I want to be healthy
and so
I kept asking I kept asking one night I
woke up in the middle of the night in a
sweat
and I run downstairs
and all of a sudden I feel the energy
coming through me and I start typing a
letter to my father
this was this is what
this was the piece that brought him to
where he needed to be before he passed
so I wrote him
a forgiveness letter
and I said to him you don't I know you
don't know me fully but this is who I am
and I told him who I was and I said I'm
sorry if I wasn't the daughter you
expected
and I forgive you for not being the
father
you were or should have been
and blah blah blah and it went on and on
this you can read in my book
and so
um
he gets the letter
I had no expectations I sent it I felt a
thousand times better again more weight
lifted off of me
two weeks later my mother calls me she
goes
what did you write to your father I said
why
she goes he called here basically in
tears saying to me he understood he
knows what you mean and he gets it
I said I'll let you read it and I let
her you know this was I was home she was
living at home and I was in my own home
I brought it to her and she goes oh my
God and in that moment that she told me
this I felt the energy shift in him
and I said this was it I said this is
his opportunity to begin to make amends
before he leaves this Earth
and sure enough
he started
and amazingly enough
of course he never makes it out of jail
why
they're gonna release him after 12 years
he only got 12 years
but
what happened was 9 11 happened
and my father was petrified that some
one of us either got hurt or was in the
city or whatever
he calls the house and he talks normal
now whenever he called from there it's
the first time I ever heard my father on
a phone whenever he would call from
there he would still talk like he wasn't
100 percent okay
Claire Isabelle they get him on tape now
he's called several times clear as a
bell
so they realize
there's no Insanity here he's not faking
anything right
so
he
the government says to him listen
unless you cop to who you are
we're going after the family for
obstruction of justice
and that ended everything
and he said nope
I'll give you everything you want
meaning about himself he will never talk
about another human being but himself
and that's what kept him there
and
2005 I think it was we got the phone
call
and that he passed her in a knife and
congestive heart failure
which you know there's a theory that
they [__] with his medicine
need the hearing or there he gets into
the spirit world and who does he contact
first one of my friends who's a medium
and within two minutes I get the phone
call you know oh no I called her and I
said my father passed she goes I already
know he's here
I said holy [__] and he said to me
the first words out of his mouth was go
take care of your mother
I dropped everything I was in my office
I dropped everything he said to me I'll
be back to speak to you personally
I go I go to my mother I go through the
whole bout of you know getting him
cremated and settled and
2005.
I wait
seven years to publish my book because
out of respect for him and my mother
but
not too long after that
he contacts three different mediums to
get to me
and I I said to because they called me
and I said look he's like a bull in a
china shop he's giving me the messages I
gotta give him to you
and they had to kind of back him off
because he would come to them during the
night while he was sleeping
so I end up then having a conversation
with him this is the first time I know
I'm a medium okay talking to my dad
and he says to me
apologizing profusely
I was wrong I did this I did that you
were right I made so many mistakes I
hurt your mother so bad
in the beginning he would never admit
that he hurt any of us only my mother
but I see now what I did and he looked
at what's called Your Life review when
you get in the spirit world and he
realized he took it way too far
his ego got the best of him and he
emitted it all of it
and I said to him I know I said but
actually none of that matters at this
point I said you are where you are and
the fact that you realize it want to
make amends is good enough for me and he
begged me at that point if he could work
with me
in what I do
and I said what do you mean and he says
I want to come through and help people
and whoever needs me now I've worked
with many in that lifestyle
throughout the course and anybody that
he felt he needed to help he would come
so I said well
that was like an offer I couldn't refuse
and I said absolutely
and so we've been two peas in a pod
since he's passed he's been phenomenal
at coming and helping me with people
when I do when I'm on stage and I'm
talking about my story or when you know
I'm doing interviews like this I feel
him he comes through me
um
it's so funny he he laughs every time
people ask me where's the money
and he's hysterical because he knows
there's like we live like normal people
we don't live
like anything other than normal people
like there is no money wherever it was
whoever had it it's not with us
so he laughs at that and I and I say to
him you know it's not funny I said but
it's okay you know but that's really
like the first question people ask I'm
so shocked at that
um
and then we go on to people want to know
the intimate details of things so you
know this is this is me telling
everybody that
you can get through anything in life you
put your mind to it you follow your own
truth and you're you're
you allow your soul to leave you lead
you and not your ego
and you got it made you could do
whatever you want I'm proof of it my
father's even proof of it because he
changed before he left this Earth and I
also tell people even if they don't
change here there's that place that they
can change in the spirit world so I
teach people to connect to their loved
ones because it's not that I don't love
being a medium but people want to speak
to their own they don't necessarily want
to speak to me so I teach them how to
get to that point because we all we all
have these skills that we're born with
it really depends on how far you want to
take it so um it it warms my heart it
gives me such a sense of you know like
gratitude that I can help as many people
either speak to their loved ones be a
conduit for them whatever it is
um but but I tell people all the time
live your truth it's the only way to go
amazing thank you that's a great story
yeah and there was so much more but I
don't know how much more you want to
hear part two part two right next time
yeah thank you Rita oh